[Música]
antes del amanecer en florida otro salto
para los vuelos espaciales comerciales
la tercera misión de la nasa y space ex
en menos de un año despegó el viernes
por la mañana una misión que representa
un hito especial para la compañía
privada del empresario y lo más que es
la primera vez que un cohete falcon y
una cápsula cruz dragón se han
reutilizado para llevar astronautas al
espacio también es la primera
colaboración entre space ex y la agencia
espacial europea con el astronauta
francés toma pesqué en la tripulación de
cuatro personas que llegar a la estación
espacial internacional
nos sentimos bien protegidos todo está
genial si te acercas suficiente puedes
ver hacia fuera
esto es lo que se ve sobrevolando
madagascar
con la cápsula de la tripulación
endeavour separada del resto para seguir
su camino hacia la estación
el cohete empezó su descenso controlado
a la tierra
los cohetes reutilizables de space ex
son clave para la viabilidad del
programa espacial comercial de la nasa
esta colaboración público-privada retomó
las misiones al espacio desde suelo
estadounidense tras nueve años del fin
del programa de los transbordadores
pesqué y sus compañeros reemplazarán a
la tripulación anterior que viajó en
noviembre y que volverá a la tierra en
pocos días en su propia cápsula spacex
llamada resilience la endeavour tiene
100 experimentos planeados durante los
seis meses que pasarán en la estación
internacional